what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and things are getting
really really exciting in the mcu with
the mutants now being introduced
officially with kamala khan being the
first mutant and not the first inhuman
like we assumed that she was going to be
but this has us asking the question what
exactly is up next in the mcu and thank
you to omaze for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit kevin feige the
president of marvel studios has teased
us that everything is going to kind of
start to get more clear and things are
going to start to connect a little bit
more pretty soon and he said that only a
couple of weeks before it was announced
that kamala khan was a mutant and only a
few weeks before san diego comic con and
disney's d23 where we expect some pretty
big announcements about the fantastic
four hopefully the mutants now that
they're in the mcu and some other big
projects that hopefully are a big
surprise to us doctor doom has been
talked about a lot recently by insiders
and are the inhumans actually not coming
to the mcu or are they simply coming in
a different way than we thought in fact
in an interview with empire magazine an
executive producer for marvel actually
gives us some clarity on the whole
mutant in human situation and it looks
like the mutants and the inhumans could
be coming so what is next for the mcu
well let's talk about mutants first
because that's what everybody is really
excited about right now we have been
teased but what is next and when are we
going to see an actual x-men team in the
mcu and for those of you who may not be
too familiar with what we're talking
about today we are going to be talking
about spoilers for miss marvel episode
6. you've been warned now if you don't
care and you just want to know about the
mutants they said the word mutation in
miss marvel episode 6 bruno told kamala
that her genes were different that they
had some kind of mutation as they said
this they played the theme for the x-men
97 animated series the theme song played
and they even put the theme song in the
credits thus confirming that the mutants
are now in the mcu but what exactly does
this mean and when exactly can we expect
an x-men movie are they going to come
out right away and make an x-men movie
or are we going to be introduced to
other mutants before we get the actual
x-men team well marvel has already set
the groundwork of how exactly they build
up teams you start off with individual
characters kind of have them
interconnect in a way until they all
come together to actually form the team
this is the avengers method and it works
incredibly well compared to say the
justice league where they simply
introduced all of them and the team at
once that didn't work so well you need
time to know the character's individual
stories and get invested in them which
is why i think kevin feige is probably
going to introduce more mutants first
until we get to that x-men team
especially if you consider at san diego
comic-con in 2019 he specifically said
mutants now he did say that the mutants
and the x-men were interchangeable words
however since he said mutants and not
x-men i think he is referring to
individual characters so we're going to
see other x-men pop up into the mcu
first and since kamala is a mutant and
she is relatively young this probably
means that a lot of other mutants exist
out there currently so who else is out
there and who else is coming well there
have been a lot of talks about wolverine
recently the russo brothers said they
would love to direct a wolverine film
the deadpool 3 writers have been talking
about who should play wolverine in the
mcu and the rumors have been going
pretty crazy about taran egerton
speaking with marvel recently perhaps
about playing wolverine as fans really
really want him to be the new wolverine
in the mcu and this isn't the only
really exciting rumor that we've gotten
recently lately there's been rumors
about doctor doom coming to the mcu soon
so let's talk about this but first i am
really excited to be working with omaze
to offer you the chance to win an
unplugged tesla s apex plaid and to
support a great cause the juju
foundation now right away you can go to
omaze.com
cosmic wonder to enter for your chance
to win and i'm not sure how many people
have been in a top of the model pled
tesla but they are insane i'm a big car
guy and i love them this unplugged tesla
s apex plaid model has 1050
pounds of torque and 1020 horsepower it
goes zero to 60 miles per hour in
1.99 seconds under two seconds and it
gets a range of 396 miles its
approximate retail value is about 259
885 but the best part is is it helps the
juju foundation which is a non-profit
organization dedicated to the support of
youth initiatives in lifting the spirits
of those in need so the cause is really
really great so for your chance to win
an unplugged tesla s apex plaid go to
omaze.com
cosmic wonder and enter now donations
support the amazing work of the juju
foundation lately there has been a lot
of talk about doom entering the mcu and
insider account my time to shine hello
says that he is coming soon she also
says that the doctor doom howard stern
stuff is pretty much fake howard stern
is not playing doctor doom in any way
shape or form and isn't really involved
why was he talking about doing a doom
project who knows this could be a
publicity stunt he could have done it
just to troll people but for those of
you who were worried don't be worried
howard stern is not playing doom but
when can we actually expect doom in the
mcu well we know the fantastic four are
coming but is doom coming before them
there has been a lot of talks of doom
entering the mcu this year and
considering the fact that we pretty much
have all of the marvel dates for this
year locked down for movies or shows i'm
assuming that the fantastic four aren't
coming this year as well and i actually
really like this because this could set
up doom to be not just a fantastic four
villain but an entire mcu villain this
would be a really great sign towards
secret wars now at this point in time
kevin feige has pretty much confirmed
everything really is leading up to an
avengers secret wars in fact the whole
secret war storyline pretty much
revolves around incursions which they
just introduced in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness in fact doctor
strange himself even caused one that's
why khalia showed up at the end and said
we're going to fix it so secret wars has
begun and who is a huge main villain of
secret wars god emperor doom so doom is
not just going to be a fantastic four
villain he's going to be a huge big bad
of the mcu now of course kang is coming
as well and they're either going to be
working together or fighting against one
another as well and i would personally
love to see that two villains going up
against the avengers the fantastic four
the x-men but also going up against
themselves probably causing one of the
villains to have to team up with the
heroes at least for a little bit so i am
actually expecting dr doom to make his
way into the mcu before the fantastic
four do and as far as the fantastic four
are concerned we know that kevin feige
is putting a lot into this movie in fact
recent reports state that marvel studios
talked to steven spielberg about
directing the movie now we already
learned from previous reports that
marvel studios does want a big name
director for the fantastic four and
steven spielberg is pretty much as big
as it gets now there is no confirmation
that he has agreed to direct to
fantastic four but just the fact that
marvel could be talking to a director
that big lets us know that the fantastic
four really is going to be a big movie
and i'm actually not sure that doctor
doom is going to be their first villain
which i'm fine with as long as doctor
doom makes his way into the mcu in some
way shape or form now as far as the
mutants and the inhumans are concerned
after making the change of kamala being
an inhuman to a mutant a lot of fans
were worried that the inhumans just
aren't going to be a thing in the mcu
however it looks like this isn't exactly
the case it looks like they just changed
this for kamala in an interview with
empire magazine the character's
co-creator and series executive producer
sana amanat said that they always wanted
kamala khan to actually be a mutant she
says here's a really important thing
that people do not know when we were
thinking about the character of kamala
back back back in the day in 2012 2013
we originally wanted to make her a
mutant that was the whole intention to
be able to do that and now in this
series they were able to get back to the
idea that kamala was a mutant not an
inhuman and she finishes the interview
by saying i will say i think this is
opening up doors for a lot of great
storytelling obviously as a huge fan um
of the word mutation i'm really happy
about it so this right here pretty much
confirms that it is simply kamala khan
that has been changed from an inhuman to
a mutant and not the inhumans in general
in fact according to insider my time to
shine hello the inhumans are still
coming but they are going to be more of
a cosmic inhuman family so for those of
you who are worried about marvel studios
getting rid of the inhumans all together
in the mcu it sounds like you don't have
to worry it sounds like they just simply
wanted to make kamala khan a mutant
instead of an inhuman so let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below and what individual
mutants would you like to see pop up in
the mcu let me know down below and don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel videos for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof